Okay, get your apron on,
and let's make some yogurt.
I'm gonna grab a couple of gallons of my raw milk here
from our cows here on the farm.
I'm going to pour it into my instant pot here.
And what you're doing here is getting the milk to 180 degrees.
That's going to help break up the milk proteins
and help your yogurt set up later on
in the process.
Drink some milk as you go.
Here I am getting at the 1 80.
Use your trusty thermometer.
Once it gets to 180 degrees,
we simply need to let it cool back down to 110 degrees.
Now, I put it in these pans to add some cold water around,
and I keep exchanging the cold water to go faster.
You can just put in the fridge or wait,
but it has to get to 110 degrees.
Once it's 210 degrees, I'll take a little milk out,
or I will pour a half a cup of just plain yogurt in it.
I'll mix it in, and then I'll dump that back into my main pot.
At this point, the yogurt is ready to be incubated.
I do that on my instant pot because it has a yogurt setting,
which keeps it at 110 degrees for eight hours.
And then at the end of eight hours,
you have this. It is amazing.
It's easy, it's delicious,
and everyone in the family is gonna love it.
Homemade yogurt, you'll never stop.
Cheers.